[Música]
tiempo para la información deportiva
aquí en france 24 estoy con luis méndez
luis vamos a comenzar con nuestro
cubrimiento especial de la copa américa
femenina que transcurre aquí en suelo
colombiano así es juan culminó la
tercera jornada del grupo b y con dos
selecciones que marchan a buen ritmo
argentina venció 5 por 0 a uruguay y
venezuela venció a última hora a la
selección de perú ambas selecciones se
parecieran definir el último lugar pero
para conocer más detalles de lo que fue
la jornada y cómo está este grupo ve
vamos a la ciudad de cali allí se
encuentra nuestra enviada especial
estefanía montero estefanía buenas
noches para usted por lo visto en el
campo el día de hoy pareciera que
tendremos que esperar hasta la última
fecha para conocer a los clasificados de
este grupo
seguramente o quizás lo único seguro que
tenemos es que no sabemos qué va a pasar
y quiénes van a estar metidas en la
pelea de las semifinales y creo que el
final de la cuarta jornada demuestra el
perdón de la tercera jornada demuestra
que esta copa américa está haciendo
bastante disputada y que las que tienen
el rótulo de favoritas no quieren fallar
a ese rótulo no quieren dejar de hacer
historia con sus selecciones hablamos en
primer lugar del partido que jugó el día
de hoy argentina versus la selección de
uruguay un uruguay que para mí sigue
siendo una sorpresa o una revelación de
este torneo a pesar de que los
resultados no se le están dando es una
selección que demuestra mucho poderío
defensivo pero que al final en este caso
por temas físicos según lo que hemos
visto en los partidos en el segundo
tiempo digamos que disminuye mucho la
carga una argentina que yo sigo
resaltando mucho la labor de estefanía
banini impresionante como maneja los
tiempos en el mediocampo como le genera
ideas a esta selección y además como
hace que sus compañeros brillen
de hoy en el partido se marcó el tri me
el primer triplete de la copa américa
femenina yamila rodríguez fue la
protagonista y por supuesto fue quien se
llevó la placa de mejor jugadora del
partido además se anotaron la misma
estefanía banini quien fue la jugadora
que abrió el marcador y finalizando
mariana larroque & cerró la cuenta para
golear aros uruguayas a segunda hora
vivimos el partido de perú venezuela o
un sinsabor con las venezolanas porque a
pesar de que han demostrado en sus
partidos amistosos previos a la copa
américa buen fútbol en esta copa américa
creo que todavía le siguen debiendo
sobre todo a su público que en el
centenario armenia las ha acompañado
masivamente
venezuela que condena castellanos y
oriana altuve lograron vencer a un perú
pero que con su fútbol por ahí no
convence mucho no es muy claro e
hicieron más por el partido a pesar de
que la suerte tampoco acompañó a la
espera a las peruanas tuvieron dos o
tres palazos que impidieron también que
pudieran abrir el marcador una copa
américa que todavía no sabemos qué va a
pasar
espera de lo que será la fecha número 4
mañana habrá jornada de descanso y todo
está por definirse nada está claro lo
único cierto es que las favoritas
quieren seguir siendo favoritas y
meterse a la fase final